our plus l equals j is a fan theory
regarding George RR Martin's Song of Ice
and Fire the basis of HBO's Game of
Thrones is one of the best supported and
most widely believed fan theories the
idea is that Jon Snow is not the bastard
son of Eddard Stark and an unknown woman
as John and most of Westeros believes
but is actually the son of Ned's sister
Lyanna stark and rhaegar targaryen so
for a bit of context Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen was the son of the Mad King
Aerys Targaryen who was overthrown in
Robert Baratheon's rebellion the war
that made Robert King
Layana is kind of the Helen of Troy of
Westeros because Robert's rebellion
started when Layana who at the time was
betrothed to Robert was abducted by or
more likely ran away with Prince Rhaegar
who was already married to Elia Martell
Rago spent the start of the war in the
Tower of joy in dorm with Liana before
going off to battle and to his doom in
the form of Roberts hammer so after the
war was over Ned and six others headed
to the tower to find Liana where they
were confronted by three of the dead
Kingsguard when the fight was over the
two survivors Ned and his friend Howland
Reed went up the tower to find Lyanna
stark in a bed of blood there Liana got
Ned to make her a promise before she
died so R plus L equals J suggests that
Diana's bed of blood is one of
childbirth
the baby is Rhaegar and Lyanna sand that
Ned's promised to lay Anna is to pretend
that the child is his in order to
protect the child from Robert who would
see the sign of the Targaryen Prince as
a threat and likely have him killed
just as he had regards wife and other
children killed in any case Ned then
comes back from the world with a baby
John who until his death he raises as
his own son in Winterfell so that's the
theory what's the evidence that makes it
more plausible than the alternative that
John really is Ned's bastard firstly it
seems very out of character for Ned
Stark
a painfully honorable person to a father
to bastard in Ned's own words to a
father John was to dishonor himself at a
dishonored catland in the sight of gods
and men Ned isn't like Robert who would
swear undying love and forget them
before even pull Ned keeps his vows so
right away it seems unlikely that Ned
would break his wedding vows to Catelyn
by father and John at one point Ned
refers to John as his blood but he never
calls him his son
at one point he internally lists his
children naming Robb and Sansa and aya
and bran and Rickon the very next line
he mentioned John but not as part of the
list of his children speaking of aya
John is said to look like her and ire is
said to look like Leanna anyway so
during a conversation with Robert about
the rebellion
Ned thinks that he has lived his lies
for 14 years
what liars are Ned referring to here's a
hint John is at the start of the first
book 14 years old so what all these
hints amount to is that John is Ned's
lie a lie that haunts him at night but
which he persists with because some
secrets are safer kept hidden some
secrets are too dangerous to share even
with those you love and trust
it hurts Ned to lie like this but he
does it to keep his promise to his
sister to protect his sister's son one
more thing about Ned on multiple
occasions
Ned opposes the killing of Targaryen
children when Robert orders the
assassination of Daenerys and her unborn
child
Ned refuses hurting his friendship with
Robert and endangering his honor and
life by disobeying the king the other
example is his opposition to the killing
of regards wife and children at the sack
of King's Landing this refusal to kill
children for the sake of their Targaryen
blood is mirrored by Ned's protection of
John to return briefly to the Tower of
joy it seems very odd for three members
of the Kingsguard to be there with lay
on a stock shouldn't they be protecting
the siblings of the now dead Prince a
very good explanation for their presence
is that they were guarding the unborn
heir apparent the son of the Prince John
so now to Essos for a biggie in terms of
textual evidence while in the house of
undying in Qarth
Daenerys has a vision of a blue flower
growing from a [ __ ] in a wall of ice
and filling the air with sweetness blue
flowers specifically blue winter roses
are consistently associated with Layana
stock at the turning of Harrenhal
Rhaegar selected Lana as the queen of
love and beauty over his wife and
presented her with a crown of blue
winter roses a storm of blue rose petals
feature in Ned's dream about Liana and
the statue of Lana in Winterfell crypt
has a garland of blue winter roses what
this strongly suggests is that something
to do with Liana is at a wall of ice
that something is very probably John on
the wall so given all these hints it
seems very likely that Johnson
is the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stock but what but what are the
implications of r+ l equals j it's been
suggested that being both a Stark and a
Targaryen makes John the Song of Ice and
Fire personified what this actually
means exactly is unclear but it does
seem to suggest that John is very
important perhaps he's the prince that
was promised or Ozora High or one of the
three heads of the Dragon or any of the
other various prophesized figures in any
case stock blood is associated with
powers like war game and Targaryen blood
is associated with an affinity with
dragons and fire John having both would
possibly make him capable of some pretty
impressive stuff a more concrete
implication is that if John is the son
of Prince Rhaegar he has a claim on the
Iron Throne
more so than Dany actually that's
assuming though that Rhaegar and Lyanna
was secretly wedded which could have
happened despite reyga's existing
marriage to Alaia polygamy is a bit of a
thing with Targaryen z' but if they
weren't married John would still be
considered a bastard and the
illegitimate contender for the throne so
he could possibly be legitimized John's
vows with the Nights Watch are another
complication he's sworn an oath to hold
no lands to wear no crown so surely he
can't be king and even if he could
overcome that barrier would anyone
believe his claim to the throne
how could he prove his parentage and
besides it seems doubtful that John
would even want the throne powers and
Thrones aside finding out his true
parentage would be very significant for
John personally he's always struggled
with rejection from karte alienation
from being a bastard and the difficulty
of not knowing his mother finding out
his true parentage would undoubtedly be
a big deal for him if not for all of
Westeros so that's R plus L equals J the
main evidence and some of the possible
implications let me know in the comments
what you think of the theory and whether
you'd like to see more videos on the
Song of Ice and Fire fan theories some
of which pretty crazy and wholesome if
you're interested in A Song of Ice and
Fire fan theories and discussion you
might like to check out Westeros org the
wiki and the subreddit that's all from
me thanks for watching this video